so let's start again with a fair coin
and this time instead of flipping it
four times let's flip it five times so
five
flips five flips of this fair coin and
what i want to think about in this video
is the probability of getting exactly
the probability of a getting exactly
three heads
and the way i'm going to think about it
is if you have five flips how many
different equally likely possibilities
are there so you're going to have the
first flip let me draw it over here
first flip and there's two possibilities
there could be heads or tails second
flip two possibilities there third flip
two possibilities fourth flip two
possibilities fifth lip two
possibilities so it's two times two
times 2 times 2
times 2 i hope i said that 5 times so 2
or you could use 2 to the fifth power
and that is going to be equal to
equally likely equally likely
possibilities
32 2 times 2 is 4 4 times 2 is 8 8 times
2 is 16 16 times 2 is 32 possibilities
and we to figure out this probability we
really just have to figure out how many
of those possibilities how many of those
possibilities involve getting three
heads we could draw write out all of the
32 possibilities and literally just
count the heads but let's just use that
other technique that we just started to
explore in that last video we have five
flips here so let me draw the flips one
two
three
four five and we want to have exactly
three heads and i'm gonna call those
three heads i'm gonna call those three
heads i'm gonna call them
do it in pink heads a
heads b
heads
c just to give them a name although what
we're going to see later in this video
is that we don't want to differentiate
between them to us
it it makes no difference if we get this
ordering
heads a
heads b
heads c
tails tails or if we get this ordering
heads a
heads c
or heads b
tails tails we can't count these as two
different orderings we can only count
this as one so what we're going to do is
first come up with all of the different
orderings if we cared about the
difference between a b and c and then
we're going to divide by all of the
different ways that you can arrange
three different things
so how many ways can we put a b and c
into these five buckets that we can view
as the flips if we cared about a b and c
so let's start with a
if if we haven't allocated any of these
buckets to any of the heads yet then we
could say that a could be in five
different buckets so there's five
possibilities where a could be so let's
just say that you know this is the one
that it goes in although it could be in
any one of these five but if this takes
up one of the five then how many
different possibilities can this heads
sit in how many different possibilities
are there well then there's only going
to be four buckets left so then there's
only four possibilities and so if if
this was where the where heads a goes
and heads b could be in any of the other
four if heads a was in this first one
then heads b could have been in any of
the four i'll just do a particular
example maybe heads b shows up right
there so once we've taken two of the
slots how many spaces do we have for
heads c
well we only have three spaces left then
four heads c and so it could be in any
of these three spaces and just to show a
particular example it would look like
that and so if you think of if you if
you cared about order how many different
ways can you can you out of five
different spaces allocate them to three
different heads you would say it is five
times four times three
five times four is twenty times three is
equal to
sixty
so you would say there are sixty
different ways to arrange heads a b and
c in five buckets or five flips or if
these were people in five chairs and
obviously there aren't they aren't there
aren't 60 possibilities of getting three
heads in fact there's only 32 equally
likely possibilities and the reason why
we got such a big number over here is
that we are counting this scenario as
being fundamentally different than if
this was
then if this was heads b
heads a
and then heads c over here
and what we need to do is say well these
aren't different possibilities we don't
have to kind of we don't have to over
count for all of the different ways you
arrange this and so we need to do is
divide this by all of the different ways
that you can arrange three things
so if i have three things
if i have three things that are in three
spaces so for any so here i have a heads
in the second in the second flip third
flip and fifth flip if i have three
things in three spaces like this how
many ways can i arrange them and so if i
have three spaces how many ways can i
arrange an a b and c in those three
spaces
well a can go into three spaces can it
can go into any of the three a can go
into any of the three spaces
then b would have two spaces left once a
takes one of them and then c would have
one space left once a and b take two of
them so there's three times two times
one way to arrange three different
things so three times two times one is
equal to six
so the number of possibilities of
getting three heads is actually going to
be
is actually going to be this five times
four times 3 let me write this down in
another color so the number
of possibilities let's write pas for
short number of possibilities is equal
to this 5 times 4 times 3 5 times 4
times 4
times 3
over the number of ways the number of
ways that i can rearrange three things
because we don't want to we don't want
to over count for all of these viewing
the this this arrangement is
fundamentally different than this
arrangement so then we want to divide it
by 3 times 2
divided by 3 i'm going to do that same
orange color dividing it by 3 times 2
times one three times two
times one
and which gives us in the numerator 120
120 divided by six
so divided by
oh sorry that's not it's 60 divided by
6. this is 60. 5 times 4 times 3 is 60.
it gives us 60 divided by 6
which gives us 10 possibilities
10 possibilities that gives us exactly
exactly three heads and that's of 32
equally likely possibilities so the
probability of getting exactly three
heads well you get exactly three heads
and 10 of the 32 equally likely
possibilities so you have a 5
over 16
chance of that happening